dude I might uh buddy - asking about
investing in a zoo actually in Mexico in
Sinaloa hugs in there Sinaloa yeah oh
man they don't have any issues out there
you should definitely do that well some
of its beachside I think if you look it
up I don't know I don't know if the end
of the visa I know a cartel would be the
main issues there that's why they need
people to come in and do that hold up
you think you're opening a zoo and
sanella Mexico and you don't think gotta
grease the palms the cartel there bro
you think you're bringing in zebras and
you bought the vet these are you think
you'll have to grease the palms of the
underworld you think you're bringing a
bearded lizard pass out chapo and you
don't have to grease the [ __ ] palms
daddy got your goddamn I'm bro dude I
look don't worry it's not I don't know a
buddy am I got a read on an animal
investor got a dude get a read and open
it somewhere close to us man all
investigate it's one forty eight hundred
to get in bro can you give me any
information to Eric give a lot of Luis
is here but can help him out Louis Wow
how do these racist right told me you
were yesterday
what are you Louise I [ __ ] called it
dude didn't call anything so I lose
native Amer but you kept calling Mexican
I did man I respect them and just kept
it very [ __ ] you man
yeah Latino yeah whatever Dario whatever
dude it says but either way he'll I'm
from Mexico he knows it's a bad idea
open up any he's from America okay
have some respect battle bro you open up
a [ __ ] petting zoo there either you
know saying it'll pettings you you ass
well it's a sanctuary for anomalous will
you give us some information Derek it's
apparently not safe to be there for
foreigners very risky and don't be out
at night the most words well maybe the
most risky Americans can't go there you
dumb Esther and open up all white people
zoo it's a daddy zoo zoo it's not a
night
I'd say what this seems like a [ __ ]
cover-up for sex trafficking that's what
it sounds like
zu that comes who's a horrible idea
animals get frisky dude what do you want
otherwise these animal are gonna be
coming up here looking for her whose bro
we need to take care of these animals on
their home court hit up Whitney Cummings
if you have a giraffe send it over right
now air quality's bad today if the other
hippo let me know I'll bring my truck
I'll be at the corner of Highland in La
Cienega 9 taking all emus and larger
that's what what her phone please no
snakes dude here's what I'm saying
Sinaloa beautiful daytime unique is
there any images if you click on Sinaloa
how about this first thing that pops up
showered in a blaze of bullets yes no
you're not openers you there you [ __ ]
click on an image you know you should do
open open a [ __ ] petting zoo in Syria
right now dude hey this isn't the spot
hold on I do want to open up actually a
company like a cling-wrap company in
Syria calls Syrian wrap no whatever dude
well listen to this man animals deserve
love everywhere and I think do it then
48 Hyundai you know and I know it's
expensive but to know that animals are
doing well there and hope one of the
whole city's on fire which one you live
on right in the middle oh that's where
they're looking I'll repeat that down
like that one oh it's just a bunch of
dead bodies that's a bunch of dead
bodies that were put in the river yeah
it's time to know when the mix was most
violent States but you know what makes
people relax and calm down guinea pigs
see I mean Molly's anomalous oh look at
the sheep I put your guns away man
forget the drugs today homes yeah I like
lambs steel Vaughn's camera over here
bro yeah bro oh look the Rat King have a
[ __ ] a porcupine up here
porcupine it'll be awesome man well look
man sorry I want to invest in Macs
dude that's how it happens people wanna
invest in Mexico they get turned down by
a guys wearing the Eagles jacket but
doesn't want to support egoless huh what
about the Eagle is a--
what about the oh do I like my flamingo
hey are there Eagles in Mexico Mexican
Eagles look it up Mexican eagle nope
bald eagle
I would assume he's the America's logo
because of you can only get him here I'm
like any bravery I found throughout the
world the bald eagles found only only in
North America you [ __ ] get so goddamn
red white and blue only found in North
America dude that's their that's the
Mexican eagle right there no hold up it
says the ball don't hold up the bald
eagle only found in North America bald
eagles are found throughout most of the
North America from Alaska Canada how
fantastic that nope I didn't see that
another part there we go well Louisa's
from Central America dude yeah dude you
kept calling Mexican I thought he was
here yesterday well he led me to believe
some things oh hey Central America
believe in ghosts
spirit day hablo pop eh see ya for male
white camera guy ghost man your mama and
papa bleep up yep yeah your mom does you
don't know if his mother does it because
he's white don't pick on him all right
everybody's there's a [ __ ] chance bro
everybody dude yeah man so look man it
luck with the petting zoo in Mexico dude
it's not for petting dude and they need
better PR for Sinaloa man yeah oh yeah
said the flames in a lot of his initial
images
back up my broccolini get your life
together I'm not